(upbeat inspirational music)
- [Narrator] Like many American cities,
Albuquerque has tried very
hard to help its homeless
population get back on their feet,
but one tactic, in particular,
seems to be working.
It involves this guy, Will Cole.
He drives around in a van
and approaches panhandlers
with an offer.
- You interested in working today?
All right, come on.
Hop in, let's go get it done.
Thank you, guys.
- [Narrator] Our story is
about a city that decided
to tackle a chronic
problem with a simple idea
that first sprang to life
inside the mayor's brain.
- Hello, I'm Richard
Berry and I'm the mayor
of Albuquerque, New Mexico.
For so many years and so many decades,
with homelessness, with panhandling,
it's always been about
buying somebody a bus ticket
to the next city and I just
wanted to stop doing that.
(telephone ringing)
- The mayor called with a plan
to give jobs to panhandlers
and I knew just the
person to lead the charge.
- [Narrator] She was
thinking of Will Cole, who,
at the time, was a security
guard at the shelter.
In a van paid for by the city,
Will leaves the homeless
shelter at 7:30 a.m.
- We ride around the city,
we locate panhandlers
at different work sites, we
approach them and ask them
if they're willing to
work and, if they are,
we take them to our work
site and we get the job done
that we're assigned to.
Thank you, Sir.
- Good morning.
- Good to see you guys.
- [Will] All right.
Either litter sweeps or pulling weeds,
it's a city beautification program.
That's what it's all about.
- My name is Martin Ramirez.
I've been homeless for almost two years.
I've been working with
Will for around four months
and he's helped me a lot.
Good work, guys, good work.
It makes me realize what I had before.
(upbeat pleasant music)
- We offer them a six hour shift of work
and we pay them in cash at $9 an hour.
All right, thank you for
the day and here you go.
Thank you much.
If I were an employer, I
would hire a whole bunch of
our clients that we pick up.
I think, a lot of time,
the situation they're in,
they don't get a chance and
I'm glad that we're able
to give them that chance
and get them started.
(whistling)
- [Narrator] In just over
a year, Will has employed
hundreds of people and they've
cleaned up 400 city blocks
and removed over 120,000
pounds of litter and the idea
has spread to six other cities,
including Chicago and Denver.
Most importantly, dozens of
people, like Mike Whitaker here,
have found permanent jobs and housing
after working with Will.
- After I started working
on the Better Way program,
I got this job doing 25 hours a week and
have an apartment of my own.
He showed me I could show
up for work every day and
do the job and be sober.
I got used to being around people again
and having conversations.
Thank you, Will.
- [Narrator] And, to bring
this story full circle,
the mayor just came up with another idea.
Will is this year's Good
Samaritan of Albuquerque.
- It just shows you how a
little ripple can turn into
a big wave and get a lot
of things going for people.
You start small, but it gets bigger.
(upbeat inspirational music)